salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique et aujourd'hui je
voulais vous faire un retour sur le
débat entre eric zemmour et jean luc
mélenchon qui a eu lieu sur bfm télé
alors personnellement jusqu'ici depuis
quelques années j'étais un petit peu
désespérée des débats politiques que je
ne regardais plus trop parce que la
plupart du temps ça s'apparente à un
combat de coqs où chacun coupe la parole
aux autres et où en fin de compte on a
plus qu'un brouhaha raoult personne ne
peut exprimer ses idées et force est de
constater que ce débat était d'un tout
autre niveau et que chacun a plus parlé
et développer ses idées de façon
relativement apaisé
alors tout d'abord commençons par jean
luc mélenchon d'un point de vue général
j'ai trouvé qu'il y avait deux mélenchon
dans ce débat celui de la première heure
avec les questions axées autour de
l'immigration de l'insécurité de de la
place de la france et celui de la
deuxième heure axée autour des questions
plutôt écolo et social clairement le
mélange de la première heure j'ai trouvé
assez désagréable traitant du trait sur
la défensive un petit peu ironique qui
lançait des pics qui donnait pas
forcément une bonne image de lui même et
par contre il a été beaucoup plus à
l'aise sur la deuxième heure avec ses
sujets de prédilection comme le social
dont il peut parler pendant des heures
et où on a l'impression que voilà il
sent qu'il est légitime et qu'il sait de
quoi il parle et donc c'était beaucoup
plus apaisé de son côté
maintenant sur le fond sur le fond on
peut noter une évolution de son discours
par rapport aux différentes
présidentielle qu'il ya eu avant en 2012
et 2017 on avait quelqu'un qui était
dans sa continuité historique personnel
qui est d'être républicain social elric
on a eu une différence sur la forme en
2017 on a eu un un abandon du tribun qui
était plus axée autour d'eux la colère
et du bruit et de la fureur
qui était un peu son personnage
historique mais qui semblait déplaire à
une partie de ses électeurs de gauche
pour aller vers quelqu'un qui était plus
axée autour d'une façon d'être de vieux
sage de pédagogue mais sur le fond on
restait sur le même discours là pour
2022 manifestement on est en train de
changer de discours et garder le
pédagogue on doit parvenir à ce qu'était
le tribun de du bruit de la fureur qui
était beaucoup trop clivant mais on a
aussi une évolution d'un point de vue du
discours qui n'est plus totalement celui
de républicain social parce que il ya eu
aussi une analyse de fait à la france un
soumise après 2007 qui était que les
fameux 600 mille électeurs qui lui
manquait pour être au second tour était
notamment des électeurs de banlieue et
donc là on voit qu'on a un discours qui
commencent à s'adapter à cette
population et qui va essayer de la
séduire
on a notamment toute la question de la
créolisation nouveau concept dont je
pense on va ré entendre parler parce que
ça va être certainement un cheval de
bataille pour mélenchon dans cette
présidentielle donc créolisation qui va
clairement l'opposé la notion purement
française d'assimilation dans lequel la
personne qui vient chez nous prendre
notre culture
et qui hélas plutôt de nous dire que les
cultures quand il y en a deux qui se
rencontrent et bien elles vont se marier
se mixer et enfin comment donner une
nouvelle culture
quelque part cette notion de
créolisation c'est le mi chemin entre
l'assimilationnisme à la française qui
est encore officiellement notre doctrine
et les théories multiculturaliste où on
a des communautés qui vivent les unes à
côté des autres
quelque part sa devise à faire la
synthèse entre les deux et il reste à
voir si ça va plaire aux uns et aux
autres
alors on a eu également des
des éléments un peu que j'ai un peu plus
bancal parce que la créolisation ça ce
débat il y en a eu aussi les arguments
pour flatter les personnes issues de
l'immigration un petit peu un petit peu
léger au niveau argumentatif notamment
l'argument comme quoi le voile c'est pas
un drame parce que nos grands mères en
france portait le voile aussi ce qui est
totalement faux historiquement
d'ailleurs on fera certainement pour la
prochaine vidéo un fact checking de
cette affirmation totalement erronée et
puis on a eu aussi l'invocation du génie
et l'associé de civilisation arabo
musulmane avec l'évocation du courant
mutazilites qui était grosso modo
l'équivalent du courant des lumières en
occident mais avec quelques siècles
d'avancé le problème avec cet argument
c'est que le courant mutazilites il ait
lieu entre 800 et 1000 après
jésus-christ et qu'ensuite c'est
totalement éteints parce que la société
arabo-musulmane à un moment a choisi
entre la lumière et l'obscurité entre le
philosophe et théologien et l'est où
elle choisit le théologien et
l'obscurité et s'est totalement éteinte
donc là on voit quand même des limites
qu'il y à a dragué une population en
faisant des références culturelles c'est
qu'elle est là pour flatter les
personnes d'origine musulmane on est
obligé d'aller chercher un courant qui
s'est quand même éteints il ya plus de
mille ans c'est quand même dire le
niveau aujourd'hui la société musulmane
donc à côté de ce cette orientation
clairement tournée vers les populations
issues de l'immigration on a aussi eu
des discours qui commencent à évoluer
sur ses propres positions pour allez on
va dire satisfaire je pense ses
militants
lorsque très clairement on a quelqu'un
qui passe de républicains sociale et
laïque à autre chose alors qu'il n'est
pas en train de devenir hook comme je
pense une partie de ses troupes mais il
essaie de trouver des positions qu'ils
soient hawk compatibles
par exemple on a eu une affirmation
comme quoi la police n'est pas raciste
mais il y à des racistes dans la police
donc on n'est pas sur une validation de
la théorie du racisme systémique mais
voilà on est quand même sur une à gauche
temps quand même de draguer une gauche
acab entre guillemets
alors je pense que pour mélenchon c'est
un petit peu compliqué ne serait-ce que
psychologiquement parce que il ya quand
même 70 ans ça fait des décennies qu'il
est qu'il a ce costume de républicain
social est là et laïque et là il est en
train de fait pour plaire aux militants
et
aux nouveaux électeurs de tenir un
discours qui n'est plus celui de
républicains sociale et laïque qui n'est
pas non plus celui de la gauche post
moderne et book mais qui se situe dans
un entre deux ou en fait il en coûtera 2
je pense de prendre ses propres concepts
qu'il a utilisé pendant des années et de
les vider de leur substance pour leur
donner un nouveau contenu qu'ils soient
comme la créolisation en fait entre ce
qu'ils étaient allemands le côté
républicain et d'un côté la gauche post
modern alors la question c'est de savoir
si ce genre d'entre d'eux va plaire aux
uns ou aux autres aussi en fin de compte
ça va rebuter tout le monde est ce que
la gauche le wok va accepter qu'on lui
dise que la police ne fait pas partie
d'un système de racisme à systémique et
à mon avis ça va fragiliser le discours
de mélenchon parce qu'il ya un moment
pour le faire vaciller vous de moi faire
vaciller ses troupes il va suffire de
lui évoqué ce racisme systémique lui
demander de prendre position au delà de
la police est ce que la société
française est structurellement raciste
et là s'il dit oui il valide ses troupes
mais s'il dit non il va se mettre ses
troupes à dos et vice versa par contre
que les électeurs s'ils valident le
racisme systémique qui est probable
qu'une partie des électeurs de gauche
vont s'en aller et que par contre 6 cl
le réfute il va il va s'attirer des
électeurs de gauche n'ont qu'à un moment
il faut qu'ils trouvent un équilibre
dans ses concepts et ça ça risque d'être
intéressant à voir tout le temps le
fragilisant par rapport à ses anciennes
positions qui étaient celles de la
france insoumise il ya quelques années
là-dessus essayer de cours de
de marier la chèvre et le chou je pense
que ça va être très périlleux et pour
lui ça va être extrêmement technique
mais en tout cas on verra et maintenant
passons à eric zemmour
alors eric zemmour j'ai pas lu ses
livres je le regardais pas en tant que
polémiste sur ses news parce que il me
semblait qu'il y avait des positions qui
étaient certes intéressante mais un peu
un peu vieille france que quelque part
en tant que enfants d'immigrés il
essayer d'être plus royaliste que le roi
ou un plus français que les français et
je trouvais que ce qu'on entendait pour
de voir des extraits de ses discours
parfois c'était certes intéressant mais
il ya d'autres fois où on se disait oui
où je me disant ce qu'il a
personnellement oui bon d'accord tu es
français mais bon tu es tu n'as pas ta
pas non plus à voile à en rajouter une
couche pour être plus français que
français et donc ce débat avec zemmour
c'est quasiment le premier que je vois
de lui et j'avoue avoir été extrêmement
surpris agréablement surpris voire même
séduit entre guillemets mais ça on y
reviendra à la fin alors comme pour
mélenchon on a eu de zemmour différent
celui de la première heure qui pour le
coup était très à l'aise avec les
questions civilisationnel
l'immigration la sécurité et le deuxième
est moore sur l'écologie et le social
qui était là quand même beaucoup moins à
l'aise et qui qui était un petit peu dit
manquer de substance très clairement sur
l'écologie on a eu droit aux éoliennes
dégueulasse le paysage et qui en plus
sont pas optimum d'un point de vue d'une
production d'électricité ce qui est vrai
mais c'est un peu léger ça devient petit
peu l'argument bateau de la droite pour
faire genre on s'intéresse à l'écologie
donc c'est un petit peu un petit peu
léger on a eu aussi un moment où il un
peu
mélenchon aurait pu le faire tanguer
clairement parce qu'ils nous a dit oui
le réchauffement climatique et
l'augmentation du co2 mais ça fait débat
je ne suis pas spécialiste je ne suis
pas spécialiste de la question il paraît
que ça fait débat parmi les
scientifiques ce genre de discours
typiquement c'est le faux nez pour les
gens qui sont un peu climato-sceptiques
et là je pense que les premiers coudron
m zemmour à mal dans un débat pointe
rang ce qui se fait là creuseront un peu
et verront que il ya un peu tangente sur
le réchauffement climatique alors la
droite il va falloir clairement un
moment posé les choses sur la table il
ya un consensus scientifique un
consensus ne veut pas dire une indian
une unanimité pardon d'accord vous avez
toujours quel que soit le sujet 3 pinpin
qui vont vous dire le contraire de la
majorité est comprise dans la communauté
scientifique aujourd'hui un
réchauffement climatique manifestement
dû au co2 au méthane dues aux activités
humaines et il va falloir il faudra
l'accepter parce que là sinon vous allez
passer pour des pour des glands et des
gens qui comprennent rien à la science
et vous avez vous décrédibiliser
ceci dit sur le reste j'ai trouvé
intéressant alors on va rester un peu
sur négatif sur l'économie et social
c'est quand même aussi assez léger c'est
à dire sur l'écologie l'économie et le
social on a un peu le discours vraiment
de la droite qui s'en fout un peu quoi
qui sait pas quoi dire alors qu'il va
dire des poncifs de droite je pas
forcément faux mais qui sont légers et
on sent que
derrière n'y a pas d'argument fait
sur les migraines coûte cher les organes
salissent le paysage
c'est un peu léger ça montre qu'on n'a
pas creusé les choses
par contre j'ai été extrêmement
emballé sur le côté surtout de sa
première heure en fait où il nous a
parlé civilisation et là on voit que
claire exams ours est ce qu est une
civilisation connaît les spécificités
civilisationnelles de chaque culture
et que chaque histoire civilisationnel
engendre une façon de penser et de fait
un fonctionnement qui lui est propre
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'il vit à
mélenchon quand il lui dit je défends
les la culture qui vous a fait naître
qui vous a créé parce qu'effectivement
l'occident est la seule civilisation qui
a engendré notamment le sociologue
socialisme le la liberté de pensée etc
et on sent là qu effectivement zemmour
c'est ce qu'est la civilisation
occidentale et quelle est sa spécificité
par rapport à d'autres cultures
notamment arabo musulmane c'est
d'ailleurs toujours amusant de voir que
ce sont des gens souvent issus de
cultures extra-européennes qui
qu'ils perçoivent mieux quelque part
pays occidentaux eux-mêmes les
spécificités de notre culture comme s'il
fallait avoir vu une autre culture avant
pour se rendre compte que les bains la
civilisation occidentale s'est certes
notre culture il faut la défendre en
tant que tel comme tout le monde défend
sa culture mais quelle qu'elle porte
aussi les valeurs très spécifiques qui
sont de véritables issus de centaines
d'années d'évolution voire plus et qui
sont pas un hasard mais vraiment une
spécificité historique qu'il faut
protéger et ça c'est quelque chose dont
quelques parcours un discours déjà ce
discours civilisationnel c'est un
discours qu'on entend pas dans l'arène
purement politique quand vous avez des
gens de droite de la droite qui vous
parle de la france de nos valeurs c'est
pour revenir à quelque chose de très
traditionaliste la france chrétienne où
on est chez nous chez nous mais c'est
pas très transcendant fin de compte
comme discours et les discours un peu
plus transcendant entre guillemets on
les entend plus tôt dans le champ
philosophique avec des gens qui comme
seymour comprennent les spécificités et
les différences entre les civilisations
et là sont des gens qui souvent
d'ailleurs son viennent plutôt de la
gauche je trouve finkielkraut onfray ou
régis debray c'est ok ou même à
l'international
c'est aussi un sentiment j'avais
ressenti quand j'avais lu fareed zakaria
inventeur du concept de démocratie
libérale qui lui est de culture à la
base indienne et où on sent que lui
aussi à la une a vu de culture il voit
bien quand on a une des deux entre 7 et
occidentale est celle qui est indienne
en plus un
depuis toujours musulmane en plus
ils voient prem canalink et une culture
de liberté qu'est spécifique que cette
culture de liberté vient d'une histoire
qui lui est propre qui est unique et qui
à un moment il faut la défendre parce
que c'est ça ou des sociétés rétrograde
et donc ce discours on les entend un peu
dans le champ philosophique et du débat
d'idées mais pas dans le débat purement
politique la droite de la droite ou même
les républicains ne tiennent pas ce
genre de discours ils sont vraiment sur
d'une bassement matérielles on est chez
nous voilà et je trouve que ça fait
vraiment du bien d'entendre quelqu'un
qui nous parle de notre culture est en
autre chose que juste notre culture
peut-être quelque chose qui
effectivement a apporté à l'humanité des
choses très spécifiques et pour lesquels
que tout le monde est aujourd'hui
derrière lequel tout le monde court
aujourd'hui ce soit le progrès technique
ou la liberté individuelle la liberté de
conscience plein de gens se battent dans
d'autres cultures pour avoir
ces progrès ces acquis de notre
civilisation
est donc ça sera compliqué pour le coup
j'ai vraiment été impressionné de voir
zemmour porter c'est ce débat là je
pense que ça va être un plus pour le
débat politique d'avoir quelqu'un qui
enfin une porte c'est question un peu
transcendantale entre guillemets
civilisationnel et pas justement
bassement matérielles
alors après pour le bémol j'ai trouvé
qu'il était quand même dans tout ce
débat un petit peu
monomaniaque entre guillemets sur la
question de l'islam et l'immigration et
qui ramenait ce sujet là surtout y
compris par exemple sur
sur les questions sociales sur la
question des prestations sociales les
logements sociaux d'accord on voit très
peu parlé mais quand une peur de
l'insécurité qui est un véritable jihad
contre la france bon il ya un moment
oui pour le coup ça fait un peu
monomaniaque et souci de ce côté un peu
monomaniaque s'est par contre ils
risquent de se fermer des électeurs qui
en dehors de cette thématique aimerait
peut-être entendre des choses plus
il ya toujours une partie des électeurs
qui veulent entendre des explications
centré autour d'une explication centrale
qui explique tout mais c'est souvent des
minorités très rigide et vous avez des
gens qui sont souvent plus modérés qui
veulent des explications on va dire
polycentrique est certes l'islam et
l'immigration sont des questions
dans notre société mais il y en a
d'autres il faudrait que aisément sont
capables
à mon avis de développer ce discours un
peu polycentrique parce que sinon il va
s'enfermer dans l'image un petit peu
caricatural qu'on a déjà de lui qui est
vrai que le champion de la culture
française et les anti immigration mais
dès lors qu'on sort de ce champ là ça
fait un peu vide ça c'est un peu le
bémol est l'autre bémol de ce côté un
petit peu psychorigide entre guillemets
c'est que si un jour il accède au
pouvoir on peut se demander qui sera
capable de faire face aux situations de
crise et les imprévus ce que les gens
qui généralement ont des explications du
monde qu'ils soient vraiment axé autour
d'une explication est bien géré dans ces
gens ne sont pas très souple
intellectuellement d'ailleurs lors
d'eire zemmour a plusieurs fois reproché
mélenchon d'avoir changé d'idée dans sa
vie alors comme si c'était un problème
rappelons
à ce cher eric qu' il ya un dicton
français qui dit qu'il est con qui
changent pas d'avis
et du coup je trouve que ce côté moi
j'ai jamais changé d'avis à risque de
poser problème si un jour il en
situation de gouverner dans une période
de crise les personnes qui sont très
centré autour d'une explication unique
du monde sont généralement des gens plus
souple et qui dans les situations créées
sont pas foutus de sont pas capables de
s'adapter et vont prendre des décisions
idéologiques au lieu d'être pragmatique
et ça c'est peut-être un côté de
l'esprit de zemmour que
que le côté
sempiternellement immigration islam
trahi ça c'est malheureusement mais
sinon réellement assez conquis au moins
sur un discours civilisationnel pour le
reste sur un discours économique on a eu
du classique mans libéral quelque part
moins intéressante le discours de
protectionniste de mélenchon
et là sur tout le reste on a en fait
quand il n'est pas sur ces sujets
principaux malheureusement on a un petit
peu l'impression d'avoir une droite
classique le côté le vieux rpr qui va
avoir des positions un peu bateau sur
des sujets qu'ils maîtrisent pas ça
c'est un peu dommage et je pense que ça
va être à travailler s'il veut vraiment
élargir l'électorat mais pour moi
aujourd'hui c'est pas une
une hypothèse à négliger pour le coup
pour la présidentielle personnellement
je suis un petit peu
un petit peu un interrogateur du coup
depuis depuis ce débat est ce que quand
on est pour défendre les valeurs
occidentales on doit voter utile entre
guillemets et votez pour celle qui sera
au second tour mais qui sera jamais lu
ou est-ce qu'on doit tenter l'outsider
qui a l'air d'être plusieurs les milieux
un peu intello dans ses discours mais
qui a peut-être plus de chance au final
parce que il est moins stigmatisés il
n'y a pas ce passif qu'on a avec avec
une certaine famille à la droite de la
droite
donc là on déjà il faut bien sûr
attendre de voir qui sera dans la liste
finale des candidats est ce que zemmour
encore à ses 500 signatures mais je
pense que ce sera un débat qu'on aura
sur la chaîne faut-il voter utile à la
droite de la droite où voter pour pour
l'outsider
donc voilà pour ce qui est de mon
ressenti sur ce débat alors n'hésitez
pas dans les commentaires à me donner
votre avis que ce soit sur les
évolutions idéologiques de mélenchon
parce que je suis le seul à percevoir sa
ou non est également sûr et bien les
argumentaires de zemmour est ce que pour
vous sa porte ou bien est-ce que c'est
un feu de paille en tout cas cette vidéo
est terminée s'il vous intéressé
n'hésitez pas à partager et à vous
abonner à la chaîne est sûre cela vient
jeudi à la prochaine